yeah I mean you know she's she's
incredible she's every perfect thing
that I have in my army hammer and his
wife Elizabeth chambers are splitting up
the actor revealed the news in a
heartfelt Instagram post on Friday with
chambers posting the same message on her
account the couple has been married
since 2010 holding like a two-year-old
and a baby in your hand then you get
spit up on one side and you got crying
eyes and you can't really be like
arrogant and all that they also share
two children five-year-old daughter
Harper and three-year-old son Ford in
the post hammer wrote quote it has been
an incredible journey but together we've
decided to turn the page and move on
from our marriage as we enter into this
next chapter our children and
relationship as co-parents and dear
friends will remain our priority
Chambers has shared several moments from
their quarantine together during the
corona virus pandemic including this
video of Ford giving his dad a haircut
et spoke with the couple shortly after
they were married really when do you
meet on Facebook no no we met we were
friends friends for years yeah no we
were friends for years before that and
what what one of your first dates as
like a kind of a kind of a newly married
couple sort of to be on the Oscar red
carpet so bad I got married in the
middle of making the social network so
when we finished social never can have
enjoyed the right of that all is like a
newlywed couple so it's been like an
amazing process
[Music]